faut-il interdire la corrida série qu'on
en parle de plus en plus de cette
interdiction de la corrida parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de gens ils
disent avec les spectacles qu'ils
reprennent ya les corridas qui
reprennent et vous vous dites vous dit
non non moi je suis pour la laque la
corrida mais moi j'ai découvert la
corrida très récemment je suis pas du
tout un aficionado là de la première
heure j'ai découvert ça il ya un an
en lisant des livres je me suis dit
c'est pas possible qu autant de grands
écrivains s'intéresse à cet art je suis
allé dans les arènes j'ai vu le
contraire de ce que j'avais entendu
c'est à dire j'ai coup vu la conte le
contraire de la torture d'un animal et
en plus d'aller voir les corridas je
suis allé visiter les élevages
rencontrer les éleveurs les toreros et
j'ai découvert un milieu qui était le
contraire de ce que de ce qu'on m'avait
raconté
ben oui c'est sûr que dans les élevages
que vous avez dû aller visiter donc les
animaux sont bien traités le temps de
leur vie sont massés c'est la thalasso
et après ils sont taillés en pièces dans
les arènes animaux à alès dans les pays
enfin dans le sud de la france alors non
pas java castaldi aussi parce que oui
mais écoutez moi je n'aime pas la
corrida il ya très longtemps sur canal+
qui était la première chaîne en diffuser
et c'est vrai que je rejoins de monsieur
c'est vrai que c'est un spectacle
incroyable c'est vrai que c'est un
combat entre l'homme et l'animal c'est
vrai que pour le coup les animaux tout
leur toutou tout le long de leur élevage
ils sont très bien traités
alors c'est vrai qu'elle est mise à mort
qui effectivement est un moment
compliqué je suis d'accord avec vous
mais je trouve que l'affrontement de
l'animal et de l'homme dans ce cas
précis voilà un sujet du jeu voilà je
pense qu'il faut pas interdire la
corrida pour plein d'envié mode vous le
dire mais pourra y avoir l'un france man
est un combat loyal
déjà c'est un contre un ben c'est pas le
cas il ya toute une escadrille qui
autour du taureau oui avait bandrélé
mais bon deux personnes qui sont
d'accord ils ont signé pour certains
combats là vous êtes ont dit ne pas
faire d'anthropomorphisme dans la cause
animale
on ne dit pas comparer les animaux les
humains et là en l'occurrence on en fait
l'autre au point mort sismondi rabat
c'est un combattant comme un autre qui
est contre un autre un autre type cas d
épée mais moi j'ai envie de vous dire si
il aime les épées si l'ism les pyjamas
fluo comme étatiste ans de l'escrimé qui
j'adore les animaux jean dignité et mon
sens un spectacle - effectivement me
fascine et l'affrontement de l'animal et
de cette bête qui était pour le coût
élevé je pense de façon extrêmement
correct et qui était la bourgade soirée
dérange pas voilà gilles verdez c'est
pas un spectacle c'est une mise à mort
voilà aujourd'hui ici sur ce plateau
tout le monde tout le temps
milite pour les droits des animaux est
non alors la corrida on accède benjamin
parce que c'est une tradition locale
ininterrompue dans 65 villes on peut
mettre à mort des animaux
c'est honteux c'est un scandale alors
aujourd'hui à vous avez vu que la mise à
mort est interdite depuis 1928 gerald il
voudra y en a
non parce qu'en fait j'entends vos
arguments je trouve absolument recevable
et je comprends que ça surtout avec tak
absolument cruel et dérangeant mais
malgré tout il ya quelque chose
moi je trouve dans la tradition dans la
dans la coutume c'est vrai que l'air du
temps c'est de considérer que la nuit
l'animal est l'égal de l'homme et moi je
ne pense pas je pense que l'homme est au
dessus de l'animal je comprends que ça
puisse choquer ça me dérange pas par
exemple quand on fait des cantons test
ou que des médicaments sur les sourires
sur les rats ça ne me choque pas moi en
tant que humaine donc voilà je comprends
que ça vous choque mais malheur de la c1
en espagne au portugal ou dans les airs
ans je vois régulièrement si on prenait
le même toro qu'on le mettait dans une
arène à paris les personnes qui
organisent deux ans de prison 30 mille
euros damende ça c'est l'article 521 1
du code pénal accorde donc c'est
interdit partout on prend le même animal
il n'a pas les il est bon il a plus
aucun droit ont-ils et dans le sud vous
parlez d'un spectacle c'est une et vous
parlez d'une mise à mort mais la mise à
mort elle commence à partir du moment où
le taureau entre dans l'arène
il est dans un dans un élevage où il est
bien traité on le mas on le rend beau
brillant vraiment le prépare comme une
voiture de course pour qu'ils se fassent
des montées dans les arènes et dans les
ateliers d'art yang c'est pas la même
chose et justice ont ils sont on l'est
on use effet m tu as vécu j'ai entendu
la nourriture si vous allez par l'art
dont on ne joue pas avec la nourriture
ne vois pas pourquoi il ya urgence à
excuser moi parler aux toreros par les
autori ils sont pas la poésie et
querelleur et aux aficionados
et puis si on entend parler aux
aficionados et celle là dans le public
excusez moi parler aux aficionados sont
là dans le public ils sont pas là pour
s'amuser ils vivent un moment sacré
alors à chacun mais je crois en hausse
avant que vous ne puissiez pas
l'entendre non j'en tirerai renom mais
je comprends que le sacré centre ici m'a
donné des français
coupez bien à écouter je suis pas je
demande la parole sont pas les éviter de
me couper s'il vous plaît oui je
voudrais dire une chose que je de jeu je
trouve importantes c'est très difficile
de faire un débat pour ou contre la
corrida de toute façon c'est un dialogue
de sourds madame dire à ces arguments et
je dirais les miens moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que il ya une chose
importante à dire c'est que à la corrida
le public ne vient pas pour voir pour
jouir de la souffrance d'un animal
pourquoi vous m'avez pourquoi parce que
on ne voit pas un animal souffrir le à
vos royaumes et attendez il ya des lois
récemment terminé laissez moi talons et
semelles et moi terminer et j attends d
ans les codeurs plus aux arguments les
entendre toute la journée
non non c'est messi on entend un
scénario je dis juste une chose se colle
au taureau montre ce n'est pas de la
souffrance
un peu vous mais j'imagine vous êtes des
cartes mais mais attendez on voit pas un
taureau partir quand il se fait picot et
il prétend chars tirent